peace
um
um
discrete
so this is a continuation of joe's uh
joe stock in some sense and i let him do
the hard part so i'm going to do the
easy part and this is a joint work with
joe and a ninja
he's also here
so uh
so the first thing i'm going to talk
about is i'm going to talk about bowel's
result which which you already talked
about in majorities tables
so
we are going to use the same notion of
noise stability that
joe was talking about but we are going
to do it both in the descriptive and in
the in and in gaussian space so let's
start in the disc this skate cube so the
discrete cube denotes stability of a
function of a set is the probability
that when we took take two random
vectors x and y that have bitwise
correlation rho they both land in the
set
the gaussian the gaussian version is
just what what we just saw so now we
look at two normal random fibers each of
them is n-dimensional standard
and the covariance between them is
exactly what we've seen at joe's talk so
the correlation between the covariance
between x and y is exactly raw
then the gaussian stability is just the
probability that when you look at these
two
correlated random gaussian vectors and
an m they both land at the set f and
that's the stability of the set f so you
can see that these two notions are very
very closely related to each other
there are some examples
uh this is the dictator set so the
dictator is just you look at one
coordinate uh deciding if you're inside
the set or not so let's say that if x1
is one you're inside the set and
otherwise you're outside the set so
what's the stability of that well
you toss your coin and the probability
that the coin lands in the set to begin
with is one half then once the
probability that the second coin lands
in the set this is one plus over two so
you get one plus over four
here's the second example you all know
this stuff so this is the majority
function we have a bunch of
we just look at the balance majority so
we want the majority of the bits to be
one then we know that there's a result
of shepard from about 110 years ago it
says that asymptotically if the number
of bits is going to infinity
then the stability of the majority is
approaching this beautiful function
which is one quarter plus arc sinusoid
over two pi
another way of seeing this
is considering the gaussian version of
the majority function so it turns out
that the gaussian version of the
majority function
is
the half space so you're looking at rn
or just at r
and you're just looking at the set of
all vectors where the first coordinate
is non-negative then it turns out that
this gaussian stability of this set is
exactly the same expression
in fact this is not a coincidence the
limit that shepard took here in order to
prove this result exactly gives gives
you this quantity all right so the
asymptotic that you get here is the
exact formula that you get
and
should i define what influences are in
this workshop i don't know so this is
the influence
uh so the influence of majority is small
the influence of dictator is large
so what is borah's results what is what
is what what joe mentioned in his talk
so this is the example for set of
measure one half so you look at a subset
of a n of measure one half then the
stability of the set is at most this
expression
one quarter plus arc sinus over two pi
which is what we saw is the stability of
a half space
is this boy's result
now this majority is stabilized
so uh
this is something that was proven with
rhino donald who is here and shishtof it
says also here so this is a discrete
version of the same statement so let me
go over it it's a little bit more
complicated if you haven't seen it
before so now we're going to look at the
discrete cube so a is a subset of minus
1 1 to the n is the uniform measure the
probability is one half and we want to
get the similar bound where now the
noise stability is the discrete noise
stability so you want the stability to
be at most this expression
however we have to impose some
additional conditions because dictator
has bigger stability than this
expression and the condition that turns
out to be the useful condition here is
we want all of the influence of the set
a to be small so they are going to be
smaller than tau if all of the
influences of the set a are smaller than
tau
then the stability of the set a is lower
than exactly this expression plus an
arrow epsilon which depends on tau
everybody is brought to this very good
okay
so
how did we prove it so when we proved it
what we did is we used moral result and
something which we call non-linear in
variance
but there was something a little
disappointing about it
one observation is that the other
direction is trivial if you know the
majority established though this implies
immediately by limiting angular
arguments broad result
and the question which annoyed us
since we started thinking about this
problem is can you prove something like
that without actually going to gaussian
space
or in particular can one give a discrete
proof of boil result
and just to give you a motivation for
doing that if you want to think about in
some philosophical level all of the area
of discrete fourier analysis started
because people wanted to prove the hyper
contractive estimate in gaussian space
and they proved it in discrete cubed in
order to get it in gaussian space
okay so everything that we're doing
right now you can think about it as a
derivative of the fact that somebody
wanted to prove a result in gaussian
space which was also
in fact already known and they said how
would we prove it in gaussian space well
let's find a version of this statement
in the discrete space the space of two
points we'll tantalize it we'll prove it
in the the space zero one to then and
then we'll get the hyper-contractive
estimate in zero one to then and that
was the beginning of of what we know the
scale-free analysis it was used in kkl
and so on and so forth so trying to
prove
to give discrete values of gaussian
statements is something that we really
like to do
so
maybe let me give you one example of the
case that this was done before except of
for the for the hyper-contractive
estimates so this is the result that
also was mentioned in joe's talk
the gaussian isoparametric results so i
won't mention this notion exactly but
in the 70s borrel and suderkovich on
prove that half spaces minimize the
gaussian surface area so what do i mean
by that you're looking at gaussian space
you're looking for a set of measure one
half i'm telling you fine for me the set
of measure one half which minimizes the
gaussian surface area and it turns out
the dance of for what is the minimizing
set is given by half spaces
so again you can ask exactly the same
question that i asked before and people
indeed ask these questions can you prove
it in the discrete discrete setup
and indeed uh sergey bobkas in the 90s
proved it in the discrete setup so this
should look somewhat somewhat familiar
to to to what you see in the previous
talk so we're going to be this quantity
the granite gradient of f squared
which at the point x is just given by
the sum of the y's which are neighbors
of x f of i minus f x squared
there's going to be this other quantity
which is i which is coming sort of from
gaussian's theory
which is i of x is little phi which is
the gaussian density and then capital
phi inverse which is the gaussian cdf
applied to the point x
and what bob could prove by induction in
the discrete cube so now we're looking
at functions from minus 1 1 to the n
with the uniform measure to zero one you
prove this beautiful functional
inequality
that i
of the measure of the expected value of
the the function f is
uh is the lower bound the expected value
of the l2 norm of i of f and and this
gradient of f
if you haven't seen it before this may
look a little scary i remember the first
time i've seen it is when gil thought
taught a course in the skillful analysis
in the hebrew university in 98 or
something so i saw this and i said why
is this nice it wasn't clear to me okay
one one one thing that you can get out
of it is that if the function takes the
value zeros and one so you can figure
out pretty easily since the density when
you go to minus infinity or infinity is
zero you get the following inequality
you get that i of the expected value of
the measure of the set f is bounded by
the expected value of the l2 norm of the
gradient of f
now the gradient of f for a zero one
value function just you know at
a specific point you just measure how
many neighbors do you have outside the
set and you take square square root of
that so this sounds like a quantity
that's related to a boundary right it's
not necessarily the most natural
in a concept of a boundary that you
think about but it sounds like a some
concept of a boundary and indeed it's
not hard to see if you do your central
limit theorem correctly that this
statement implies pretty easily
that for every set in r in rn
i of the probability of the set is a
lower bound for the surface area of the
set and this inequality is exactly
borrel's inequality it is exactly the
borel and pseudocode silicon inequality
for the gaussian surface area of a set
okay so again the philosophy i didn't
explain how you prove this right but you
see an inequality like that is
inequality in minus one one to the n
it's a function inequality you hope you
can prove something like that by
induction and if you also get bobcat you
can prove something like that by
induction actually the proof is not so
hard if you know what inequality you
want to prove
once you have this inequality instead of
applying it to functions you apply it to
sets this is a similar philosophy to
what we've seen at job stock you apply
to sets you get some
more geometric inequality that relates
to sets in little subset of zero one to
then then when you take two you take the
limit you get the gaussian result that
you were after
okay
any questions so far
okay
so we are going to try to do the same as
majority established so we want to prove
the following statement by induction of
the dimension
we want to show that if a is a subset of
0 1 to the n or minus 1 1 to the n
then the noise stability of a is bounded
by this
shape out function
plus an arrow where the error is small
if the influences are small
so that's what we want to do that's what
you want to prove by induction
unfortunately for us we already know
that instead of proving the set version
we should prove a functional version
and since we had this previous work
where we knew what the functional
version is it was
pretty easy to guess what do we need to
prove so this function j
that we saw before that satisfies this
boundary condition conditions that at
one one it's one if you have at least
one coordinate that is zero then is zero
and what we want to prove instead is we
want to prove the following inequality
we want to prove that
what we've exactly seen at jawstalk we
want to prove that the expected value of
j is less than j of the expected value
but now since we know the dialog terms
we expect that there should be some
error terms here
this is what we're going to prove
it sounds very similar to the statement
that you've seen in the previous talk
the only difference is now we are
looking at the discrete cube
so we're looking at this function from
the discrete tube to the interval 0 1
this matrix which is exactly the same
matrix that we've seen before it's it's
the matrix of second derivatives except
you multiply by rho the mixed derivative
if this matrix is negat is a negative
definite then the expected value of j of
f x g of y
is upper bounded by j of the expected
values plus arrows
depending on f and g which are small if
the influences are small
that's what we want to prove
okay so this is what we're going to
prove
so we saw this function before
and if you put if you look at the values
one half one half you'll get exactly the
probability that two correlated
gaussians are both going to land in the
same half space which is this expression
okay very good so how do we prove it let
me actually try to prove it
so we're going to do it by taylor
expansion which is what james was
looking for
at the break so we're going to expand
this
using taylor and we're just going to
look at the taylor expansion of j so
there's going to be a bunch of terms
there's zeros terms this the first
degree and the second degree term we are
going to expound around what we're after
which is the expected value of f and the
expected value of g so the zero stance
is just going to be j of the expected
value of f and the expected value of of
g
what is the first order term well the
first order term like in many of these
proof
proofs we're going to use to use the
fact that x and y separately
each have expected value zero
so if you look at the first order term
you look at the partial derivative at
the expected value but you multiply that
by the expected value of x and by the
expected value of y so you're going to
get zero so the first order term is
going to vanish what about the second
order term well the second order term is
not so pleasant it looks like that so
you look at the
hessian and you reply to x y x y
so note that there is no o here
actually if you look at this expression
what are you going to get well in the
diagonal terms you are just going to use
x x and y y in the non-diagonal terms
you are going to get expected value of x
y here an expected value of x y times
here so you are going to get one and one
on the diagonal and you're going to get
row and row over here so you're going to
get
exactly the matrix that we've seen
before where you multiply the
non-diagonal diagonal terms by row and
now if you want you can replace the two
variables x and y by x and x since this
matrix is a non-positive definite math
is a negatively definite matrix this
expression is going to be is going to be
negative
okay so what what did we have so far the
zero order term is what we're after the
first order term is zero the second
order term is non-positive so what we
get is we get that the expected value of
j of f and g is less or equal to j than
expected value of f and g plus an arrow
and the l is going to be a third order
it's going to be involve expected value
of f minus the expected value of f to
the third power and similarly for g
okay
so this is the base case
now the inductive step is essentially
immediate you don't really have to do
anything
so you're going to condition on x1 and
y1 you're going to fix them
and if you fix them you know once you
fixed x and y x1 and y1 you can just
apply the induction hypothesis so you
get exactly this expression plus the
arrow of order n minus 1 involving the
function f and g
and now you're going to apply the base
case
this is just a function of one variable
just a variable x1 this is a function of
one variable just a variable y1 so we're
going to apply the base case to these
functions and what you're going to get
is you're going to get that the expected
value of f and g is upper bounded by
what you want plus the expected value of
the o of
error of order n minus 1 when you take
expectation over x 1 and y 1 and the
expected value of the error of order 1
when you look at the two expectation
condition on x 1 and y
so we are just going to call this arrow
epsilon n
so what is this error so if you write it
down you get a pretty nice expression
so what is f i here
so you have a function f
and many of you know the multi-gal
method what is the multi-goal method you
look at the sequence of functions f5
where you condition in more and more
variables so f0 is just going to be the
expected value of f f1 is going to be
the expected value of f condition on the
single variable x1 and so on and so
forth you reveal more and more
information
so epsilon and f if you follow the
analysis that i've just done epsilon f
of f is just going to be
this expression would just look like the
martial difference except usually when
you look at multiple differences you
look at the second power and here we get
the cell power right so this tells you
that if the difference is so small you
are going to expect that this quantity
is going to be very small
that's what's going on here
and indeed if you want to prove borel
result just from this just looking at
this expression
if you do the standard approximation
what you get is you get the difference
between f i and f i minus one when you
approximate some continuous function is
going to be of order one over square
root of n so when you take the third
power it's going to be like n to the
minus three halves when you sum over all
the n variables you're going to get
something that's going to go to zero so
you're going to get to recover bouel's
result like that
and unfortunately
similar philosophy applied to if you
want to prove the majority established
unfortunately again you have to use
hyper contractivity so why do i say
unfortunately we all like hyper
contactivity that unfortunately comes
from the fact that usually when you get
hyper contractivity you get estimates
that are not very nice i mean you lose
something in terms of the dependence of
epsilon and tau okay so you get the same
loss that there is in all the previous
results
which raises the questions if this this
is indeed necessary
okay
so now
why is this interesting uh it's not
clear why is this interesting uh you
know we saw various spoofs of boys
resolved by now so uh
as joe mentioned there's uh
our result the previous scissors the
proof of rhyme and
guide for special cases
and there's the proof of bowel and so on
and so forth so why do we need another
proof
so actually what we've seen in jos and
joe's talk and maybe what we're going to
see right now is that you know extra
poofs let you prove extra stuff
yes
so okay so i didn't actually okay so the
question is what do we want what do you
want me to prove right if i want to
prove majority established i have to do
some hypocontractive estimates which
either you know how to do or you don't
want to see okay it's not it's not very
unpleasant it's a little unpleasant
right
right so just a second so the induction
statement is done
yeah okay so this is the index index the
induction the inductive statement says
that the expected value of j is less or
equal than j of the expected value which
was the gaussian statement plus an error
term the arrow time is very explicit the
old term is just given by this multiple
difference to the third power so that's
the end of the inductive statement now
i'm deriving the covalent of this of
this this derivation
right so where do we influence so let me
let me try again well
let me try to explain again where
influences are coming so influencers are
coming in the fact that what you would
expect it's not completely obvious but
what you would expect is that if
influence of on the function f are small
then these expected expected values are
going to be
are going to be
of all those of some out there and when
you take it to a start power it's going
to be much smaller so it's not going to
be concentrated or value close to one or
minus one or zero one it's going to be
somewhat smoother not because you know
the the function is low influence so the
chances that you're actually going to
change is going to be small to actually
argue this rigorously you need to use
the hyper contractivity okay because you
know it could be that the first val the
last variable is actually has a lot of
influence right it's right one side
condition all the variable but but one
the last variable typically you know
it's going to change the value from zero
to one right so the fact that you know
the fact that you have a third power and
low influences actually means that this
expression is small requires a little
bit of a proof which i'm skipping here
okay but maybe just for the intuition
you can think that one special case of
low influence functions is the case
where you know try to approximate some
gaussian function right so there's some
gaussian function i'm trying to
approximate it by boolean function how
am i going to do it each gaussian random
variable i'm going to write as
a sum of bernoulli under variables
divided by square root of n and then
what i'm telling you is that when i look
at f i minus f i minus 1 it's going to
be typically of order 1 over square root
of n where n is the total number of
variables of the function or up
total number of variables of the
function is maybe n times the number of
the original functions
variables of the original functions and
when then when i take the third power i
gain this factor of one over square root
of n which means that the error is going
to go to zero
okay
okay so yes that was the end of what i
wanted to say about this and let me tell
you a little bit about some of square
proofs because the organized organizers
asked me to say something about sum of
squares proof so let me do that so
uh
so what are sum of squares proof so some
square tools
proofs that let you prove statements
about polynomials so suppose you have a
polynomial of the following form
uh it's a sum of
sum of a
expression each of them is a sum of
squares each of this is a polynomial
each of the s is polynomial
time some products of polynomials each
of them is positive in the set that we
that we're looking at
so obviously this polynomial is
non-negative
okay because it's sum of positive
expressions multiplied by no negative
expression so it's going to be positive
so this is not a very interesting fact a
much more interesting fact is in some
cases for example if the set a is
compact and the value of a general
polynomial is positive on the set then h
can can be represented in this form
so let's think about this this fact
again
so i'm looking at a compact set i have
some general
a multivariate polynomial that's
positive on this set so i claim that i
can write this polynomial in the
following form it's going to be a sum of
expressions each of them is of the
following form this is a sum of square
and this is a product of polynomials
each of each of this polynomial is
completely positive or completely
non-negative on the set that i'm looking
at
okay so this is the proof that this
polynomial is positive right i'm giving
you a polynomial that positive the proof
that is positive is the fact that i can
write it in this way
okay again a is the set that is defined
by this polynomial
right so this is
very good so this is an existential
result so the question is what do you do
this
is existential result well one specific
case that is interesting is the case
where all of the polynomials that we're
talking about here on the right hand
side are of degree at most d then it
turns out that you can actually find
this representation in times that is a
polynomial in the number of variables
and an exponential in the in the
integrity
okay
so this kind of
statements about polynomials are called
sum of squares
statements are proof for proving that
this polynomial is positive
so why are we doing real algebraic
geometry here
we should object to that
so we're doing real algebraic geometry
here because the sum of square proofs
are very closely related to to the laser
hierarchy
and
this connection recently was highlighted
by the work of these people which starts
with barak and ends with you but i don't
remember all the people in the middle
i'm sorry and then there was a paper for
donald and jew and the
the connection to the celebrity which
was known before but was highlighted and
you know much much more developed in
this in this to work is that we can look
at the
optimization problem so suppose you want
to optimize a function h of x
subject to the constraint that it lies
in the set then it turns out that the
cell hierarchy
and the sos arc are the same or dual if
you want
so
the statement that h x is positive on a
has a degree d sum of square proof if
and only if it has degree d or the other
two last relaxation that gives you a
value that is non-negative okay so the
two statements are the two ways of
looking at this problem are the same or
dual of one each of each other so why is
this interesting
right
so yes so uh
so the history here is involved and i
don't want to offend people especially
dead people
right so uh no i mean this i mean it's
no but
but there are people who are even before
us i mean this this this this this field
has been this field as as as a lack of
result and i'm not sure i know all of
the history this is the statement that i
gave right now is definitely not from
the recent papers but it goes back a
while ago i'm not sure who was the first
to prove it do you know ryan alexander
do you know
right but it might have been denying the
in the real algebraic geometry community
right so it's second
mean
the subject definitely goes to gilbert
to hilbert's problems but this statement
statement i think goes to goes back to
people who are not not not not among us
anymore right but i'm not exactly sure
who are they do you remember joe no okay
okay yeah yeah we can compare i mean
there's also the question of how
explicit things are right so you know in
the sum of the mass literature some of
these things are not necessarily that's
this explicit
i wish i had more information about it
like
i've my student omar thomas
has a beautiful thing for this kind of
situation it's amazing that in the past
people used to argue about facts
okay now you just take google out and
you start looking and you know the
answer it's going to take a little bit
of time but there is a good math survey
paper which contains many of the
references which we can look at right so
yeah i don't know
i don't know off the top of my head
like this paper is it it's the same it's
the same it's the same area it's the
same there's no i mean
yeah in terms of the proof system it
themselves it's exactly the same proof
systems and it's exactly the same
semi-definition or the same
semi-definitions
okay
uh right so that's the conclusion so sos
proof shows that the
relaxation is accurate
and what one of the callers of what we
did is the majority established as a
constant degree
approximate sum of squares proof
and why is this
interesting did i prove that to you
right i can do what joe did which is to
tell you that everything is easy okay so
i'll just tell you that so this is easy
we want to show this statement right
which is you know with some error
depending on f and g
what we're going to do we're going to
put it first in dimension one and sort
of by putting our some fancier version
of putting any true statement that just
involves a finite number of variables
you can prove with an sos proof there's
a slight technical issue here that j is
not actually a polynomial but you can
approximate j by a polynomial and then
you get a two statement
you can get that if you pay a little bit
of an epsilon you can get that the
statement is two and therefore there's a
finite degree proof of the statement and
then what you see is what's nice about
our proof and the reason that it didn't
work so well for other proofs of
majority stability is that the inductive
the inductive step you can immediately
immediately translate to the from the
normal proof that we had before so you
really don't need to do anything except
you have to use
hyper contractivity and for diaper
conductivity we need to use some of the
tools that we already used
in barack and al and we actually used
the papers of line and you because it
was easier for us to read okay so that's
what we were doing
yes yes
so i mean here you've done that in seven
you have this
three majority of stables kind of
statement
maybe the main the main advantage of
this approach is that you have a
statement that is an analytical
statement that doesn't talk about zero
one sets right if you if you want to
talk about events that have value zeros
and one there's no nice polynomial ways
of even phrasing them and the point in
what we're having right now is that the
statement that you have involves smooth
functions and once you have smooth
functions you can talk about polynomials
right that's a very good point so maybe
the point is not even the proof it's
just the fact that you have the right
statement that involves polynomials and
once you have the decide statement the
proof should be easy even though in our
proof we actually use the fact that it's
an inductive proof so you know it gives
you an you know an additional power when
you actually want one to carry it
and like in job proofs when they say
that something is immediate it means
that you take 20 to 30 pages okay so
just i want to just want to make this
point clear
okay
so uh
but still what why is it significant to
have some swelling very good why is it
significant to have some of square foot
so one of one of the reasons for that is
is related to hardness of approximation
so
everybody is in the room so in joint
work we
yeah of course
the best case is the case of one
variable
yeah so the basic so we want to prove
this kind of statement
the point of the statement the point of
what we're trying to prove is we want to
prove that the degree is bounded as a
function of epsilon the error that we
have okay
so uh if you have one variable it's just
a statement about polynomials in one or
two variables right so it's a statement
about a compact set in r2 or something
right so a statement about the compact
set in r2 that involves polynomials of
polynomial approximations of j instead
of j you know some version of putina
tells you that this statement this
statement must be true there is a finite
degree with the proof of this statement
does that mean
we prove it but for one variable for for
one variable who cares about put
optimization problems one variable right
so that's not very interesting on its
own yes
that's the equivalence term
we do it for one variable
yeah so this is i mean it's not an
industry statement of itself on its own
but if you care about the lesser
hierarchy that's what it says and then
the other the other ingredient of what's
going on here is you know the fact that
our proof is an inductive proof and you
don't pay too much in terms of the
degrees of polynomials which is
something that has to do with the form
of the proof means that you can go from
the one or x x and y variables case to
the to the case of many many variables
into or you're getting small integrality
or you're big integrating up yeah yeah
the ratio is going to be
as bad as it gets
right so one of the most confusing thing
about about this is that you know what's
used to be good you call bad and what
used to be bad you call good so this is
supposed to
to confuse everybody yes
right so that's when i said exactly
right so when i said that we're very
good so you know eventually you squeeze
the proof out of me so when i said that
we're using a version of putting our one
of the things have to do i have to deal
with the fact that we have to preserve
this this
semi definiteness but you can do that
right yes and in particular there's a
version of putin now that you know shows
you that not only if a polynomial is
positive you have a proof of that but it
also shows you that if a matrix is
positive semi definitely there is a
proof of that and we're using a version
of this statement in our proof yes
in general it will say that for a
specific candidate family which was
supposed to be a lower bound it's not
allowed very good so let me thank you
madhu for letting me go to the next
slide okay so let me go to the next
slide so what what's part of the
motivation for for studying this so part
of the motivation is what's the hardness
of max cut so there's this the result
with subash and guy and ryan were all
here where we showed that under unique
games the hardness is
is
zero is this value zero point eight
seven eight
and in fact now we are talking you know
if you you were at the talks that in the
afternoon yesterday of maduro and other
people one of the things that you want
to do is you want to say well if i have
hardness
in the conditional sense i also want to
have hardness in the unconditional sense
but for weak families of algorithms like
the laser hierarchy or some linear
linear linear
linear
programming hierarchies here we're going
to talk about some definite hierarchies
and indeed people were considering it
even before our result so fargo and
checkman showed that you know the
standard algorithm for serving max guts
which is the the government's williamson
algorithm exactly has this gut okay so
this is a very this is a very strong
indication of hardness
and then court and vishnu
construct a different family that also
has this gap for a more sophisticated uh
semi-definite program which involves
what's called the triangle inequality
and this is a much harder example and
you'll be given these two examples one
may hope that you know actually there's
you you are able to construct examples
that like in medustar yesterday actually
survive linear rounds of the last
hierarchy or something
and this is not true and this was
already proving the vapor of for donald
j so they proved that you know the gap
instead of being okay i don't know if
this is as good or as bad as 0.878
but it's it goes down
goes down goes up to 0.952 for this
example that that we used in the cotton
vision and to some extent this is the
most you know this already shows that
you know we are not getting this kind of
picture at least from the cotton vision
construction and i think this result is
somewhat less interesting but our result
says that in fact this this example of
cotton vision has no gap at all right so
the ratio is one so you know there's
if you want to amplify it there's
nothing to amplify right there's really
you know this example is not going to
survive let's say hierarchy okay so this
is sort of the semi-definite programming
part of the story i think i ran out of
slides so i'll stop here thank you
question
i
of uh think status yes you have to use
the fact that f is a positive value
function it's bounded above by one
so where does that
okay so the original proof i mean the
functions have to be actually not just
positive they have to be strictly
between zero and one
right because
right and j sort of gets crazy when you
get close to zero and one right so in
fact in order to control the
in order to get a good polynomial
approximation of the function j i
actually have to you know as a function
of the epsilon that you're after you
have to truncate the interval a little
bit so it's going to take you know it's
going to take value between epsilon and
1 minus epsilon and then there's going
to be a good polynomial approximation of
the function j the function j is sort of
crazy close to the the endpoint 0 and 1.
and you don't care what happens
outside outside right i mean we it's not
we care a lot but there's nothing we can
do about it either function is just
crazy right
i will try i will try
yeah
so somehow i didn't understand
it at all i mean
so there is a proof that the
but this is a conditional statement this
says that if unique games
is hard competition
now you can ask for a different question
i have a very powerful family of
algorithms algorithms which is all the
last hierarchy algorithms up to level
n over login okay this is a very strong
family of algorithms let me prove that
for this family of algorithms they all
cannot do better than this value this is
the kind of lectures that we had
yesterday afternoon okay so for some
problems for which the you know the
the the approximation resistance or
harms of approximation to some factor is
known the same results are carried over
to very strong families of algorithm
like the hierarchy up to linear linear
levels linear in the number of variables
so you want to prove it for all these
algorithms i want the point for these
are going but this proves that the
example is the best example the best
candidate that we had so far for proving
such a thing fails
algorithms also assuming unique no again
these are unconditional statements these
are very strong families of algorithm
which do not cover everything they don't
allow you to play all kinds of
combinatorial tricks and so on and so
forth so very strong firm is the
algorithm and you want to show that
these families of algorithm all fail as
would be predicted by dishonest results
this is already so this is not true and
this is not true
right so it's it's it's it's a good
contrast to this the talk that we've
seen in the afternoon yesterday well
okay harvest of approximation results
also held in the hierarchies in in
so this
shows
right exactly
and make sure that it's even more
natural
in the sense that they show okay you
know this example still has a gap right
so you know
there's no gap at all
which is a very very smart if
i can say very very smart a nice example
and you know and and it's the best thing
that we can come up with
no but but it's not surprising that if
you just want to go from the haiti
example just by adding one simple
looking inequality i didn't like
surprising i said it's hard
no but then now we are adding so many
more inequalities so it wouldn't be
surprising that it would take another 10
years to
construct an example so no sure yeah but
sorry this is consistent with what i
said it will take you ten more
okay thank you
this